Hi. I'm Cliff Mori.
I'm an advanced cicerone.
If you aren't familiar,
the cicerone program is kind of the beer
world's equivalent
to the sommelier program for wine.
Today, I just want to show you guys,
if you quit tap to enjoy better
beer at home.
So any time
you're drinking beer at home,
you want to pour it into a glass.
And the reason
why is you're getting
a lot more of the flavor in aroma.
It's always a good idea
to give it a little quick rinse.
This rinsing
is going to remove any dust
that might have accumulated
any weird cabinet smell.
And we're now ready to pour.
So open up my can of beer
as I begin
to pour out and start
pouring down the side of the glass.
And as I get towards the top
I'm going to start pouring
just a little more aggressively
because I want to get some foam
at the top of that glass of beer.
Foam is delicious,
popping bottles of beer smell.
It's going to really enhance
that flavor and aroma experience
When buying beer,
it's really important to remember
that beer is perishable.
Beer goes stale.
It can never hurt you.
You can find a 40 year old Budweiser
in your grandfather's basement
and drink it,
but it's not going to taste great.
And craft brewers, they want you to drink
fresh beer.
So berries are always going to put
a little date coat on the can.
Sometimes you'll find it
on the individual can,
sometimes you'll find it on the package.
But take a look at this
when you're at the store,
because anything
that's more than four to six months
old is not going to taste the freshest
There's a really popular beer
myth that I'd like to bust for
you guys today.
And that's the idea
that if you let cold beer get warm
and then chill it down again,
you somehow ruin the beer for beer.
Cold is always better,
the same as a gallon of milk.
If you keep it in your fridge,
it's going to last a lot longer
than the trunk of your car.
But letting cold beer
warm up and cool down again
is not doing anything to that beer.
The question I get
asked a lot
is which is better
bottle versus can and for beer?
There's really no flavor difference.
And the old days cans got a bad rap
when you put into a can came out
tasting like can candy technologies
improved a lot.
There's food
grade liners inside every can now
and so that cans not hurting your beer
at all.
Bottles do have a little risk
of getting hit by light
and light has a nasty reaction
with the hops and beer
that creates a compound
that smells like a skunk.
So for me
if I'm choosing between bottle
or can of the same beer,
I'm going to choose can
Your nose is a huge part
of your flavor experience.
And if you're drinking out of a bottle
or a can, your nose is being left out.
The standard shaker pint
glass is the wrong shape.
If you notice here, it flares out,
meaning it's an inverted funnel.
So those aroma compounds
that are so important,
they're being diffused out
instead of focused towards your nose.
This glass here,
more of a tulip shaped
glass, is going to do a lot better job
getting all those aromas and flavors
from the beer to your mouth.
Craft beer is work
really hard to create
delicious, flavorful beers.
And as consumers,
let's give them the respect they deserve.
We need to buy our beer fresh,
pour into a glass
and enjoy every aroma, flavor, check.